I should have think of who was it was it
was it new in Toronto I think when I
asked y'all to line up and I said okay I
want you to be the same distance from
the fence of the basketball courts and a
super puzzle which I think was an errata
okay so here we go these are bets right
there's a line and here it is and here
is a point the position of a person okay
now what we're now after is what's the
equation of the locus that is
equidistant from these two features
okay so there's some point this is what
we looked at before
it has coordinates X Y because what why
why do I call the coordinates X Y well
yeah that's right we don't know what
they are and they can do their variables
right they can shift around so these
values there could be different things
but it can't be just anything right they
have a certain properties we've seen
circles we've seen a perpendicular
bisector a couple of perpendicular
bisectors and what shape the weekend
from this you may remember this shape
that we started to trace out out of the
basketball thoughts but how can we show
it algebraically okay so to begin with
we're going to month put some names on
these where you got this DVD this line
I'm gonna call it yd for reasons that
will become clear enough suit so if I
want the distance from pain to the line
to be the same as the distance from P to
the point what should be like the first
line that I write that demonstrates that
relationship yeah
okay even before I write what the
distance that are the square is what is
that square root where did that come
from
yes dear which by the way you are
talking about the can you start with the
square root of donor bra that's the
distance between those two points right
and then I want that to be equal to this
is between the point and the Y which I
suppose I could call this s this is the
point that's me this is the point that's
moving right and I want the relationship
the distance between these two to be the
same as the distance between oh so
that's P SFPD right by though this is a
sort of signal to you when you're
converting all that wordy stuff into
impatient right because P is the point
that has the relationship that's equal
right
he needs to appear on both sides of the
road does that make sense so now that I
know what I've equated I want to
actually have some expression to do
right so PS that's a pair of points I
know how to do the distance here and off
goes the Q's what am I gonna have
underneath spirit I've got X minus 4 or
square
if you thought you got those coordinates
fantastic okay there's my distance
formula no big deal when I get to the
right hand side I'm doing the distance
between a point and a line which of
course is a perpendicular distance right
so to do the perpendicular distance
formula I can't quite work with this can
I actually need to modify this just a
teeny little bit how should i rewrite
that equation
so all I've done there it is somewhat
redundant form is I've written this in
general form right I've written to 0
then in K there is an a it just happens
to be 0 I've written the one in because
there happens to be a big and that's
Italian right and there's the constant
once you get it in the right spot so if
that's ax plus B Y plus C and this is
the point that I'm comparing it to what
is this sum perpendicular disciplines be
a little while what's to stop yeah okay
I'm actually gonna write because what I
have on the top here is ax 1 plus B Y 1
plus C that just so happens that in this
case the X 1 y 1 are X&Y
that's the point I'm comparing to right
so those are the coordinates there they
are right there
x1 and y1 they just happen to be in this
case x and y that's all the numerator on
the bottom I have remember it's gonna be
yeah Pythagoras just like this right so
it's the square root of a squared plus B
squared which is the square plus B spit
are you happy with that
all right now before we do anything to
this right you can see I'm gonna have
something nice and neat on the
denominator great it's gonna vanish away
I have a square root over here and I had
an absolute value area here and we're
expecting that these two are gonna need
to talk to each other now in the past we
had like a square root on both sides
what do we do when you saw that we
squared both sides and that was okay
because we had square roots of both
sides were both positive we're adding
any more solutions or anything like that
it's the same deal here this has to be
positive swear it
this has to be positive cuz it's an
absolute value so I'm going to square
the whole water okay that gets rid of
these
and over here as rap point now this is
really just what was three that's that's
really all it is
once I square it I need to worry about
the absolute value because a square is
also positive so I have this okay now
again before we just go by this lead to
crunchy the algebra even though we'll do
that right
what do you expecting will happen you
notice before you expand these you can
see you're gonna wide square here and
you'll have a y squared here just one of
them exactly right
since you've got exactly one of both
sides then they both should cancel each
other out
does that make sense okay so you're
gonna have some wine charms some x
squared X terms what it's time to
anticipate just so when you get there
like okay this is what I was expecting
let's expand so how are you mean here in
the yeah we absolutely good I'm gonna go
ahead and expand this and then we'll do
that
this is a 60 now if I bring this over
here as we suggested you don't have to
do this by the way
spread okay so this doesn't my
originally intended part but I have a
problem with it this is difference of
squares here right
so these factorization of difference of
squares is a minus B a minus bit down
okay what happens when I do a minus B
the Y's will cancel with a and then I'll
get three minus negative three we just
see okay when I do a plus B it would be
the wise the kids'll it will be the
threes the kids do you see that that's
okay so this is we come to life that's
just why a minus B and that's my April
plus big UK with that by the way you
didn't have to do that I think these Mel
visits didn't match up
you wouldn't gain a huge amount out of
it but it works just fine
all right now I'm almost there on time
right I could all look alike this is
twelve Y if I like this in fact I don't
really really need to have expanded this
all right I haven't gained very much
adverts baby I haven't gained any of
inside these terms over here have all
sort of cancelled with each other so
it's not like I have a constant over
here that's also mixed with this okay we
didn't know that in advance so we just
expanded I'm going to tidy things up I
have twelve wife yeah I'm gonna pop this
back in its factored form because
factorizing is usually useful to us and
then I'm going to make Y the subject
okay what can you tell me about this
firstly what kind of a shape is it it's
clearly a parabola right
it's in a normal y equals rav4 okay by
the way what what form is this what does
this tell you
with parabolas you basically have you
really got three options right it's I'm
in general ax squared plus BX plus C
that's what for
doesn't look like that does it you have
a completely factorized form and then
you have vertex form okay that just so
happens and just particular case that
those last two are the same this is a
factorize as you can get right but it
also here is like I'm gonna be this is y
minus 0 right so I've got my x
coordinate my vertex there a my
y-coordinate one vertex there that make
sense what difference is happening that
that has to do with like steepness or
fatness separately let's draw this guys
let's draw here and let's include these
pieces that were talking about before
draw yourself upset axes
16:12
all on 1260 no 12 will be so that's four
thirds then for number three is gonna be
oh sorry I ran out of space okay we have
the general Indian let's have a look
scales not the greatest but we have the
general picture here right there's that
parabola there's my vertex which I got
out of that textbook okay
there's this point up here now this line
I have drawn this line here I'm trying
to jot it it's not an asymptote okay
which is you start to run out of
different ways to apply it it's like
well should I do in like Morse code or
something okay but this line here it
clearly tells us something important
about this right I want you to remember
what happened when you were all standing
against the fence
and this and so for example I pick a
point like say there now how does that
point satisfy this kind of property that
we were given right
well the distance between P there's one
example thing and that fixed point that
was uh provided okay is the same as the
distance from my point P and this line
over here and don't forget it's
perpendicular
okay so I've got this being to this okay
so what have we created whatever is
rated this particular laughers when you
are equidistant from a point and a line
this is the locus of a parabola we
recognize the shape you started as soon
as you saw this equation come out even
by this point down here you could start
to guess they were Y squared to cancel I
have recognized this
so more generally speaking the locus of
all points that are equidistant from a
given point a the line is a parabola